hội đại biểu tòn của cuộc đảng lên thứ mười bốn là một sự kiện chính trị quan trọng
với đại sự phát triển của đất nước trong giai đoạn tới.
Thế điểm này, như dân cả nước đặc biệt quan tâm, tìm hiểu và đong khóc những ý kiến tâm viết
chất lượng vào dự thảo văn kiện chính đại hội.
Nhìn kiểu dự thảo văn kiện đại hội mười bốn của đảng,
ông phản văn hốn, phó giám đốc bởi vì đa phó hại dương thành phố hại phòng,
đặc biệt ấn tượng khi trong dự thảo lên này,
yếu tố hạnh phúc được đưa vào chủ đe của đại hội mười bốn.
Đặc hạnh phúc của nhân dân là mức đau trong mọi chủ triển chính xác.
Nhìn phản đến không, trong xóc, sự phát triển người dân,
thì ở đây chúng ta này cảm miền với cái đất sống,
nhưng mà thì một cái trị số này sữa hạnh phúc thì năm nay đã hội.
Nếu thù hội bồ đợi cái trị sữa hạnh phúc vào,
thì phần kẹn đầy này mà mọi cán mà,
thì ta này cứu nữ người dân được được hưởng sống ở nó mà hạnh phúc lúc như những gian
trị đạo của thù hệ phổ xin mình hàng mong.
Trưa thảo ván kẹn đại hội mối bốn của đăng,
còn nhấn mạnh bái trò chung tâm của con người cho phát triển.
Không chỉ dừng lại ở việc nâng cao thu nhập,
mà con hướng đến phát triển toàn diet con người Việt Nam về chi tuệ,
nạo lực, thể chất, tinh thần và kinh nâng sống.
Tâm dình chính đợt và thầy đại thị văn kẹp của đá xalic.
Nên mọi đuộp để xa đường kẹt tinh hoàn quá thử dễ tạm,
tình lai và đặc biệt là khúc địa cập gió,
sự tế đổi rướng mối như đổi rộng,
và rộng sáng của nhập xo dọc,
và đưa con người văn hoàn.
Sáng tạo cho thành chú cột phát triển.
Không chỉ là ký tế mà cả xấu của văn hoàn.
Ký tế hai đầy đủ,
những thành tíu thức,
và đã nhìn gió chắc đường bốn người làm đồn mối,
và giúp ra và học kinh nha,
và lấy cương người làm trúc tâm đồn mối của mình tắt,
và kết được hệ hoàn.
Dân tọc, sự mạnh thử đại
và cũng đã đưa vận,
các cái trúc chương trọng đình hướng.
Giáo dụt cũng như văn hoàn,
ý tế, để lần cao lấy hệ phục của nhé dân làm trúc tâm.
Bảo cáo hệnh phút thử dưới năm 2020,
chỉ số hệnh phục của Việt Nam
tăng bà mấy bệnh bật.
Tự sẽ thẳng tảm bà năm 2020,
lên sẽ thẳng bốn sấu năm 2020.
Vyệt đưa yêu tố hệnh phục,
vào dự thảo văn kẹt chình đại hộn mối của đàn,
được giết dân cả nước mạnh giả cao,
tắt mệt kì vọng và tinh tưởng và mọi trụ chương,
chính xe của đàn và nhé nước.